listening into the interview with
Michael Gove responding to some of those
claims in the Sunday Times this morning
now you've cause have been quite
reluctant to criticize the government's
response so far has that changed well I
have to say I think Michael goes line
that one or two aspects of this story
are off Beebe is possibly the weakest
rebuttal of their detailed expose in
British political history I mean look
none of us expect to be impossible we
understand that mistakes will be made in
a crisis of this nature but there are
serious questions as to why the Prime
Minister skipped 5ive cobra meetings
throughout February when the whole world
could see how serious this was becoming
and we know that serious mistakes have
been made we know that a flatline NHS
staff don't have the PPE that they've
been told this weekend that they were
that they wrote Nestle have the gowns
which are vital to keep them safe we
know that our testing capacity is not at
the level that it's needed we know that
the ventilators that many hospitals have
received are the wrong types of
offensive aters and there are big
questions about whether as to whether we
went into this lockdown too slowly and
now we hear the Prime Minister missed
five meetings at the start of this
outbreak I mean it suggests he is yes
but early on he was missing in action so
we do need to understand what was going
on and it's not good enough for the
Chancellor of the Duchy of Lancaster say
or one or two points were off be equal
deserve an explanation and it's
disappointing I'm afraid but Michel girl
who wasn't able to give a full
explanation a few moments ago at the
same time though the government has
successfully and rapidly ramped up
capacity in the National Health Service
there's questions about whether they
acted too slowly but we're still really
tracking or the rates they've been of no
deaths very sadly that we've seen in
other Western European countries - I
mean that doesn't really chime with
evidence that we've done much worse or
at or more slowly than our neighbors
well I have got nothing but praise for
the National Health set in the way in
which they've opened up the Nightingale
hospitals across the country and it does
look like this and some spare capacity
in those hospitals at the moment and now
we need to
about how we use that's their caste
whether we can use that help with the
crisis in our social care sector for
example now you talk about the fact that
we are doing a sort of active line with
some of our European neighbors but
Germany are testing far my people a day
than we are and Germany has a much lower
death rate for example so we need to
understand why testing has not been
ranked top to the levels which are
sufficient why contact tracing has not
been ramped up yet we're in a lockdown
now we supported a lockdown who support
is extension but we should be using this
time to prepare for the next phase
fighting this virus and that means
investing and testing and contact
tracing but it also means being clear
with the British public about what
happens next
we still not have that clarity and
transparency for ministers to talk a bit
more about the exit strategy but just on
testing we could hear Michael go fair
saying that they're wrong course to meet
that target of a hundred thousand daily
tests by the end of the month do you
think they'll meet it well problem is
government ministers holders will be
doing 25 thousands in twenty five
thousand tests a day by now and we're
not so we need to understand why the
government are failing on the promise
that they made the mid April
of course if they meet their target
about hundred thousand tests a day that
promise of a hundred thousand tests a
day that would be welcomed but we've got
to go further because a lockdown is a
blunt tool in and of itself
we need a testing and tracing strategy
alongside it to help us manage and cope
with this virus
whether for the for the coming months so
let's see where we get to but you know
so far the government hasn't MIT met its
the promises it's made before of our
testing now let's talk about the exit
strategy if you like from the lockdown
shall we Michael go very keen to not be
drawn into specific saying that the
government be guided by the evidence but
labour of course has called on the
government to lay out its exit strategy
what does labour think that should be
well we want to see what the government
plans are I mean I think as I was was
suggested in Scotland we should be
treating people like jump triple our
people are grownups and people need to
understand what happens next because the
lockdown in itself is not a strategy it
is
a tool as part of a strategy but given
that we know a vaccine might not be
available for 18 18 months we need to
understand what is the government's plan
between now and when a vaccine is
available we need to know whether the
government have a serious plan to extend
testing in the community and contact
racing but we've got for example 750,000
volunteers who signed up to help in this
in this outbreak because some of those
people help be helping with the contact
tracing where are we on the apps that
have been taught about there's an NHS
England app being developed there's
another app being developed by Google
and Google so you know and what we're
hearing that the two apps might not be
able to interact with each other I mean
what's the government's response on that
front and also you know as we go through
this process of coming out of lockdown
or relaxing some of the lockdown
measures we still need reassurances that
our national health services will be
able to cope and yet there's still not
got the PPE in our NHS we've heard today
how the British the British health care
trading association offered to help the
government back in February and now
those offers fell on deaf ears and every
MP aids in box or certainly my inbox is
awash with small firms across the
country so they've tried to help the
government with PPE
they've tried to tell the government
they can manufacture PPE and they hit a
brick wall they don't get anything back
from the government whatsoever well
there's a lot of wartime analogies used
throughout in this process well why are
we using all that small firms like we
did with the smart the small boats in in
Dunkirk why are not we not supporting
British manufacturing getting our firms
manufacturing the PPE to keep our NHS
start say these are the things that the
government need to tell us about which
is why we're calling for more clarity
about the next stage of the of the
outbreak it's one thing calling for more
clarity on the next stage of the
outbreak for a like a roadmap if you
like how to the lockdown but at the same
time we're not sure that we passed the
peak yet the death numbers are still
heartbreaking only high is there not a
risk that by talking so much about the
lockdown and the exit strategy that
you're confusing the message that people
need to stay at home now I think people
understand that in stay at home and I've
got a British public have been
tremendous
ensuring great resolve staying home and
I think we should be hugely
congratulated for that but also don't
forget a lockdown has other far-reaching
health consequences as well
it means operations cancelled it means
people with cancer having their
treatment delayed it's leading to an
increase in mental health problems and
of course a lockdown impacts on the
economy and this is significant because
if if as a result of this lockdown we
see unemployment rising poverty rising
but that will have an impact on health
outcomes as well in fact The Lancet
suggests that a 1% increase in
unemployment leads to a 2% increase in
chronic health conditions so all these
things need to be taken into into
account when looking about them looking
at the next stage of our fight this
virus because our guiding principle
should always be to save lives but we're
just asking for the government to give
us some clarity just asking for the
government to tell us what is going on I
mean the government are not even
publishing the minutes from the stage
committee they've said they're going to
publish the stage committee minutes
after the pandemic has ended that was in
New Scientist just in the last 24 hours
I mean that's not clarity that's not
transparency you just want to cook
government at level with us so we could
understand what the plans are